monsieur au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles le procès de gaston
dominici commence
l'accusé dans le box les avocats ont
revêtu leurs toges les jurés ont été
désignés le président du jury peut
débuter son interrogatoire
tout semble réel sauf que gaston
dominici a déjà été jugé en 1957
vendredi dernier l'association
jurisprudence de l'université versailles
saint quentin proposer une
reconstitution de ce vieux procès où les
parts d'ombré aux toujours persisté à
l'époque accusé de triple meurtre gaston
dominici avaient été condamnés à mort
mais aujourd'hui tout est encore
possible
il ya un véritable doute et du coup je
me suis laissé convaincre qu'il était
véritablement innocent et je vais du
coup essayer de convaincre qu'il est
lui-même innocent pour juger cette
affaire tout a été reconstitué les
preuves seront exposés et des étudiants
en droit joue le rôle de l'accusé et des
témoins déguisements et accents compris
à côté des acteurs en tenue un public
bouche bée des improvisations qui font
sourire alors à la justice serait-elle
en réalité du simple théâtre c'est
beaucoup de théâtre c'est beaucoup de
comédies un bon avocat
s'il plaide doit être un très bon
orateur s'il veut remporter ces dossiers
ne pourra pas signer un bon orateur
c'est peut-être ce qui avait manqué à
l'accusé à l'époque car les jurés joué
par les proches des élèves ont déclaré
cette fois-ci gaston dominici non
coupable